what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to lana
rhodes talking about the humiliating
things that she did when she was a porn
star
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel
um and ring that notification bell that
way you're going to be notified of my
daily videos
um i should mention like she's like
crying she's not just like
i don't know that's what the thumbnail
it was her crying
i i don't know what she says in it this
is like blind as usual
it comes to that so what i was talking
about like being pressured
um to do like more and more things more
hardcore things so there's
two different main genres of porn
there's gonzo porn which is
the aggressive porn that you guys are
talking about it's the rough anal sex
it's the choking
it's and i'll go more into that and then
there's um
vanilla porn which is what olivia is
talking about as um
ethical porn is what i think you would
consider
um it's just like classic like
missionary like just like basically like
artsy
science anyway i'm kind of laughing the
inside because i've had someone call me
vanilla before
i mean i love bananas like why are you
still vanilla i'm like what do you mean
it makes me kind of hungry but i like i
would i've never even heard of the term
gonzo to be honest yeah
so gonzo is
i've never heard anyone refer to porn as
art
it's interesting
the first level of it i would say would
be just it's just like there's no like
artistic vision to it it's just like
rough hardcore sex
and that could be vaginal penetration
the next level up would be anal
penetration
in a gonzo style and then there's
a level far more than that and i would
say that
during my time in porn i'm not sure what
is like the hype right now in porn it
goes through like different phases
but during my short stint and porn um
the really extreme acts were what was
popular and that's why
being the number one performer in the
industry at the time everyone wanted to
make money off me so they pushed me to
do these things
um and it just gets really extreme like
you were saying abusive
did you ever feel like did you ever go
through those experiences where you
had to do a scene where it was very
aggressive and you've just felt like
yeah i mean i don't want to go into too
much detail like honestly some of my
experiences are really humiliating for
me
and i wish that they never happened
there's stuff going on like people
getting pissed on
men are pissing inside of women's
vaginas [ __ ]
down their throats they're
sorry oh don't cry
but like and this is what
i mean when
like people don't real i mean obviously
she's extreme it's like
porn but like there's a lot of girls
that do like lesser things and you have
to realize you're selling
like pieces of your soul when you do
that and you can like look how sad she
is
and i bet it was like a slippery slope
where she agreed to one thing and then
because she agreed to that they kind of
pushed her
to agree to more and more and more but
and but she
you know made her bed so she's to like
lie in it but
yeah i don't know like i have some
empathy for these girls i know no one
else does
um like guys i hear them like react to
her all the time and they have no
sympathy for her but
i don't know i have some sympathy for
girls that are like young when they have
to make these decisions
and they're just offered something
that's tempting and they end up doing it
um but they end up a lot of times
realizing later that they sold their
soul in order to do it
tell me something no i'm crying i'm like
god damn it
no don't cry i'm just giving some
examples but
no that's honestly that's really hard
and i think like i had mentioned earlier
it's just so important for young men to
stop you being stop viewing
women as sex objects because i believe
that you know instilling that curriculum
in school i'm gonna be honest um
that's the wrong approach in my head
because
there's always gonna be creepy guys like
no matter what you do no matter how much
you instill it and like
people in parenting and schools whatever
they're always going to be creeps
and i think it's a lot more important to
teach girls how to say no to
like things they don't want to do and
teach them how to avoid creeps
and avoid those situations rather than
just
say like let's change let's change men
like creepy men are going to be like oh
well since she told me to let me just
change like come on we'll edit her age
and
they had actually said there's a fact
that says that
the more a young person had learned
about the use of pornography from their
school education
or sex education is less likely to see
women as sex objects and i feel that's
why
oh my god okay i i disagree with that
if i had any school tell me that these
grown adults that i don't know
are going to be teaching my i don't have
kids but my future kids
about porn no no i don't care what any
study says
no absolutely not you know i i feel so
passionate about the porn industry
because i don't believe that they should
be showing those types of scenes because
it does
view women as just an object and it's
not okay to do that like i enjoy
watching porn
like girl but you have to like you have
to also realize
you shouldn't be doing those types of
scenes like you're playing into the
industry by doing it nobody put a gun to
your head and made you do it
i'm sure it was a lot of pressure i'm
sure that they
you know um were really like gave her a
lot of money whatever and i totally get
that i have empathy for that
that's a tough situation to be in but
i don't think like again i don't think
the solution is
let's police what men like what
consenting people want to do
i think it's more what she's doing now
which i actually really respect lana
rhodes for which is coming forward and
saying these are the repercussions
don't do it and teaching young girls
like these are the repercussions for
your actions like i
you know but like i want to watch
ethical porn i wanted to be normalized
and i wanted to be taught to where
it shouldn't be to where a woman is
being abused and
is you know like the male is showing
aggression because that actually is
going to translate into his
relationships with women in the future
his wife like it's actually
statistically proven that it's going to
show aggression
in a marriage in a relationship and
that's i mean how is that healthy that's
not healthy at all well a lot of it is
like young boys don't understand and
they think that this is normal and
that's what girls want so they've
probably never been with a girl before
and they see these horrible things
and they're like oh this is how to
please a girl this is what i have to do
this is what she wants and then they you
know do these things and they act
certain ways and they don't realize
the effects that they're having on women
yeah well they do say that
serial killer and rapists are the ones
who are consuming these
extreme types of horns a lot of um
serial killers when they've gone through
their search history they're watching
like
these abusive porn and there's tons of
pornography
on their surroundings i mean i'm not i'm
not gonna lie i obviously like i said
i've watched porn i do
yeah i mean i've stumbled wrong with
watching yeah but i've stumbled upon
some videos where i'm not gonna lie
i really questioned why is this even
allowed on the internet like i felt
very like i was just turned off i was
like
shut my laptop like i can't even look at
this i was like i cannot believe that
this is
okay like this is not okay to treat
women like this yeah
well i i know that i got emotional but i
do want to continue giving examples
of some of those things just so people
know
um what are we but what were some of the
things that you saw that you were like
wow this is
really crazy yeah i mean there was one
scene where i had seen
um obviously the the male was having sex
with a girl and um
she was literally crying because he was
being so aggressive like i guess you
know he was just too big for her
i mean she was like full-blown crying
and he was like
slapping her like you like that like you
know i was just like
oh my god how can this like i could not
get off to this
i don't know who watches this too some
people have that fetish and it's crazy
that's why they put it out there because
they're like oh somebody will watch it
which is
just like yeah offense but like that's
disgusting because obviously she's not
okay
yeah yeah and i mean but
but here's who's i have a hard time
saying
if this girl is consenting and wants to
do it like
for that amount of money
i mean it's sad but if you agree to it i
don't think
you should legally be able to stop them
i mean to me
it's just it okay i have to think
through that a little more but like
right now that's
that's my answer really makes me sad
because i think of the girl and i think
wow like
i can just see in her eyes that she did
not want to do the scene
but she's doing it because of the
reasons of you know she needs the money
or this is a flexible job for her right
now
she was convinced she was pressured you
know she was manipulated into doing this
by her agent because he
you know told her like it's either this
way or the highway like i can't even
imagine how that girl felt having to do
something that she clearly
does not want to do like this is not
acting like she's full-blown crying
you know like i there's just no way
she's acting and enjoying this so
yeah i've had friends who have been
choked
out so much they've actually passed out
during a scene
there's really just like crazy stuff
going on that damages people's bodies
for the rest of their lives
i luckily don't have any issues but i've
seen scenes shot in europe where
guys are literally punching into a
girl's [ __ ] like this
i'm like she's i don't like that
going to have issues for the rest of her
life due to this
and is it worth someone making a little
bit of money
and someone jerking off to it um
one of the worst honestly i feel like
i'm in denial sometimes and i can't
accept some of the things that i've done
there is one thing that you know i tried
talking to a therapist
about before something that i had to do
for a scene
that was really rough for me um
basically this guy had a bowl and
he like gagged me until i threw up into
it and then he like pissed in the bowl
and during the scene he asked me to
drink it
and i didn't know how to say no it was
one of the most disgusting
foul scenes i ever had to do
and i'm telling a therapist this and
they don't even [ __ ] know what to say
to me
yeah no one can relate like no one
[ __ ] knows what to say about it
and so when it obviously so obviously i
don't know how like porn is shot
they don't tell you beforehand does this
did they tell this guy to
to do these things or did he just his
own brain this one my agent was actually
very pissed about okay and again like
i'm not saying that i was raped i but
you were put i spot you i
told this guy like yeah i'm excited
let's do this
i just i didn't know how to say no i i
didn't
i just wanted everyone to be happy so
it's i can't blame anyone all that i can
do now is make the best of my
experiences and accept it
which is really hard for me to do um
sorry what was your question again yeah
that's
yeah that's that's really all she can do
and i do respect her for coming back and
actually being honest about
like the repercussions of her actions
and like
telling people that this isn't all like
sunshine and roses which a lot of porn
stars will just like
act like they're happy and glad they did
it which i i don't see as truly genuine
but at least she's coming forward and
like spreading awareness about the
repercussions of this sort of thing
i'm i mean not like and a lot of people
think she's like like saying this for
pity and i don't think she is
i think she's really just genuinely
expressing like
issues that she has with the industry i
think you pretty much answered my
question
but no i was just gonna you know um
chime in and say
about how you had to do something that
you know you didn't want to do or
you felt pressured i definitely can
relate to that just even by like working
out hooters i know i mean you have work
there
i obviously have a little longer history
of that and you know i definitely was a
sex
object like that's who i was viewed as
working at hooters
clearly i was the complete opposite of
that but you know i definitely was
pressured into some things that i didn't
want to do
with men um they had the audacity to ask
me to literally go give them a hand job
behind
the dumpsters yeah you know
it's not funny no it's like it's like
comical
it's comical behind a dumpster i was
really thinking first off why not at
least the car
yes dumpster second off can you imagine
you're at a restaurant and you have the
audacity
to look at your
did she do it well can you go jerk me
off behind this dumpster
no but they would they would push my
limits like they would just kind of joke
around at first they're like oh
um and they i'll give you sometimes too
you know
yeah and you know they were like oh i'll
give you a hundred dollars if you take
off your panties for me and you know i
was vulnerable i was young i was like oh
like no harm like okay like he just
wants my panties like heck yeah a
hundred dollars like that and they're
gonna keep
they're gonna be like they kept pushing
and that put me up and once they like
put you on the spot like
it's so hard to like say no when you
feel so awkward because you don't want
to one ruin a relationship with a client
who comes into hooters every single day
who is basically paying your bills
who's tipping you you know two you don't
want to piss them off to where they're
gonna go say something
so you know i i definitely can relay on
the pressure thing and i can
i can definitely understand how you felt
like being put in a situation that you
did not know you're going to be put in
because it is so
hard to get out of that so you know like
i definitely
understand sex workers and the porn
industry a lot more just because i've
had personal experiences that i can
relate to
uh how that would kind of give me like
you know um i actually have a lot more
empathy for
women that were in that situation um
like i've never done like sex work or
anything but
um i think a lot of girls are very young
when they're put into a situation
where they're they have to make
decisions that they're maybe not mature
enough to make
so just my two cents but let me know in
the comments if you agree or you
disagree with me
um do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and
bring that notification bell help me get
to 20 000 subscribers guys
love all of you i will talk to you next
time